hello everyone so I need to take this
symbolism thing into more serious
questions now when something appears on
the horizon of our world let's say
something that doesn't make sense
that's when you have to start paying
attention to it this is precisely would
happen with the Peppe meeting last year
during the Trump campaign and that's why
I felt it important to analyze it the
Church Fathers that they often speak of
this notion that the most mysterious and
revelatory things in the Bible or in
tradition are found in the ambiguous and
the seemingly contradictory texts and
that's where in something that's when
something is clearly in front of you but
it doesn't fit and that's when you have
to pay attention now in the past week
we've seen many articles in the
mainstream media discuss the surprising
use of of an obscure horror movie
monster the babadook as an LGBT icon
online now and in Pride celebration this
figure is being framed as a gay
character even though at first glance
neither
the character nor the movie has anything
to do with the question of gender or
sexual orientation so when when reading
articles on the subjects you can feel
the writers being somewhat uneasy and
unsure of what this means while still
strangely celebrating this association
so what's happening
every every movement every group every
ideology
has a network of associations under it
which make it exist these patterns are
what makes something itself and not
something else
now four important movements and
situations this network of associations
has underlying symbolic structures
archetypal the structure is one could
say and the proponents of this this
group or this movement they're not
always completely aware the extent of
this web of analogies which underlies
what they what they are and what they
think and so it's precisely when an
image pops up as an icon and say as a
representation of something despite all
logic all normal intention that's when
we should focus on that thing to
understand it because by all logic the
LGBT community who's pressing for
acceptance and recognition they were not
strategically associate themselves with
this demonic force this pathological
state which wants to bring a mother to
murder her child but that's what's
happening
so I never heard of this character of
this movie I mean partly because I'm not
really interested in horror movies but
because of all the brouhaha decided to
watch it and it and it's really kind of
suspense movie and we rather than a
straight horror movie in fact it's not
very frightening at all so I'm going to
present you with an interpretation which
takes into account the lens let's call
it of gender and sexuality because see
that's what's happening
after that you can all make your own
conclusion as to what to what the movie
and this figure means in relation to the
question of gender and sexuality so the
movie is about a woman whose husband
dies in a car accident on the day she
gave birth to her son that's how the
movie starts we see the accident in a
dream and her son wakes her up telling
her that there's a monster after looking
through the house to no avail the boy
stays in his mother's bed and sleeps
with her now
remember to always pay attention to the
beginning of a movie so that's for the
movie will reveal itself in those first
moments in terms of gender this movie is
about one thing the absence of the
father it's about the absence of the
masculine in fact the boy is surrounded
by girls during the whole movie the
other mothers whose husbands we never
see who fear his aggressive behavior
he only interacts with girls he he goes
to a princess party princess birthday
party where he's told by a girl that
they don't want him there that he's not
good enough to have a dad and all
through the movie the boy makes these
weapons right he he he does all these
nice these kind of boy things and he
does it to save his mother from the
monster his mother keeps taking away his
weapons here maybe with reason down and
once the boy he he he climbs and stands
up at the top of a swing set and and
then his mother and her friend they
she's freed they freak out and she takes
him home as he's screaming in the car
and another moment when the boy goes
down into the basement to interact with
his father's things the thing that his
father has left after dying and and he
talks to his father he he tells his
father that he's going to defend
mother from the monster and his mother
freaks out and right there at that
moment in the movie the only other
significant male character shows up and
the character shows romantic interest in
the mother he brings her flowers brings
a gift to the boy with things degenerate
and the young bored screams he screams
that she won't let him have a birthday
party so there you have to read that she
will not let the boy grow up will not
let him become a man and then he also
screams that she won't let him have a
dad so if you have not picked up on it
yet what we're dealing with here is an
oedipal mother who's devouring her son
who both want to protect him at all
costs
but also hates him profoundly because
she sees him as the cause of her losing
her husband so it's Oedipus all the way
here no holds barred and with the son
constantly in the mother's bed it's hard
to ignore this theme the was the
mother's bed is a constant image in the
movie and the fact that the son sleeps
in her bed is emphasized I mean there's
even a scene where the son interrupts
the mother at one point when jumping in
her bed when she's well let's say she's
busy so enter the babadook who hides in
the closet either he's a masculine
figure with a top hat and a trench coat
and he's sane so he's not a normal
masculine figure but he's a predatory
masculine figure he wants to possess the
mother so that she finishes her job as
the oedipal figure that she kills her
son and as the ruling progresses we
discovered that the baggage by the build
is really masculinity itself for he
appears to the mother in the very figure
of the father
so the babadook slash father tells the
mother to give the boy to him to give
the boy to the masculine predator who
demand that you let him in movie
emphasizes because at some point when
the mother is fined and not being
possessed by the moment of this force of
the babadook begins to abuse the boy
directly and throws him around so once
the mother finally defeats the babadook
then her relationship is with her son is
normalized she she celebrates his
birthday and the movie uses is very
directly mail images she praises the boy
for being good at darts and she she kind
of helped him to be better at darts when
before she wanted to take away his darts
and his weapons and she praises his
masculine capacity to transform reality
and she watches him do a magic trick
where he uses the very masculine image
of a wand to transform potential in this
case it's a coin and money is always an
image well most of the time money is an
image of potential and so with his wand
he transformed this coin into a dove the
babadook is still there though I mean
these things they don't go away he's
locked in the basement and said only
worms so it seems that the only thing
missing and I was hoping to see this
happen at the end was the only thing
that would be missing would be that man
who had showed some interest to the
mother could have made his final
appearance to confirm that the pathology
had been fully managed let's say
now there could be other interpretations
of this movie I mean it can be seen as
relating to depression obviously but if
we see it through the lens of gender
because that's what's relevant right now
that's what was started in this
discussion of using babadook at an LGBTQ
icon so we're looking at it through the
lens of gender where we have we have the
absence of the father which brings on
pathological feminine it brings on an
extreme oedipal relationship and its
shadow desire to give in to the
predatory masculine who wants a young
boy for some reason who hides something
under his clothes and if you saw it
would make you wish you were dead I mean
it's an interesting movie it's actually
not a particularly good movie but it's
interesting until now
I'll let all of you decide why the
babadook is an LGBT icon